- Please welcome Sabrina Carpenter.
(audience cheer and clap)
- Oh my God.
This is very surreal.
- It's such honor to have your
presence here on the show.
You started at nine years old.
- Yeah.
- So how did you know
yourself well enough at nine
to be in touch with what you could do?
- I don't think I knew anything.
I think at nine years old,
you just love what you love
and you just gravitate towards
what you gravitate towards.
I think for me,
I remember watching the
"Wizard of Oz" specifically,
that was a very vivid memory
watching Judy Garland sing
just before I was nine
and I was just in awe.
And I was like, "Oh, I wanna
do that forever if I can.
- 'Cause if you started singing at nine,
and putting yourself out there,
was there an earlier year,
was there a moment in your life
where you had the, I wanna do this moment?
- Yeah well, I specifically remember
there was a restaurant I went
to when I was six years old
and there was a waitress there, Patty,
and it was her birthday.
And I was like, "Oh, I wanna
sing happy birthday for you."
And so I sang her happy birthday.
And then every time I came
back to that restaurant,
she made me sing happy birthday
to anyone in the restaurant
who had a birthday,
which some people started to gimme money.
And I was like, "Oh!"
I was like, "Is this is my career?"
And I was six, so I didn't
really know what I was saying.
My parents were like,
"You can't take that."
And I was like, "Are you sure?"
I was like, "'Cause this is my business."
- I mean, I'm so glad.
Thank you, I was like, I
wanted to know a moment.
I love that so much.
You have amazing taste in music.
- Oh, thank you.
- I mean, who are some of your
favorites and inspirations?
- So many, I think.
One of the first songs
my mom ever played me
was Etta James "At last"
and Patsy Cline, "Crazy",
(audience clap)
- [Drew] Dolly Parton?
- Don't get me started on Dolly.
Dolly's my favorite to this day.
I love her so much.
I love Carly Simon.
I love Joni Mitchell, yeah.
- I mean, who, how did you find?
You have amazing taste in music.
- Thank you.
- How did you find it?
- I think throughout the years,
honestly, if anything, I feel
like I've really come back
to artists like Joni and
Carole King, and Marvin Gaye.
There's so many incredible artists
that I just really gravitate
towards the way it makes you feel.
And the instrumentation of their songs
just kind of makes me feel
like elevated and alive.
So I don't know,
I guess just like through searching.
- You are always in songwriting mode
and you're very prolific.
- [Sabrina] Thanks.
- And you attack it in the moment.
One of the reasons I fell
in love with this story
about you is it felt like
inspiration not lost.
How do you remain in
constant songwriting mode?
How do you capture it?
What is that life?
- It's interesting 'cause
I'm a little paranoid
because I am always really
listening to the things
that people are saying,
sometimes maybe too in depth.
- Like on social media,
or live and in person?
- Oh, I would say more live and in person,
social media, scary.
I think live and in person,
you really get this unfiltered
version of conversations
and things that people aren't
necessarily calculating
before they say
so you'll have really,
really honest thoughts
and sometimes things that you go,
"Oh, I can never say
that to a real person."
Or, "I can never put that in a song."
And I think that's been
the main inspiration for me
is what are those moments
that we feel like we
shouldn't say or we can't say,
and those are usually the best songs.
(upbeat music)